okay rookie you've learnt the basics of
guerrilla warfare but I'm here to tell
you why we fight and how we're gonna
reclaim this city zone by zone the red
zone is the most decimated area in
Philadelphia but it's also where the
resistance has established a foothold
then ain't gonna be glamorous you're
probably gonna die
ah speeches like that among the bombed
out ruined abandoned streets now a
guerrilla tactics are having a real
effect against the KPA
in a red zone we target strategic strike
points important to the KPA
taking these over will help turn the
tide in the resistance is favored
strengthening our hold in the zone
freeing up safe houses and giving us
greater access to supplies and equipment
you need to get over the armory and help
prepare the ambush me and Dana are gonna
round up as many fighters as we can to
meet you over there
to take out armored kPa patrols we
planted traps all over the place and set
up ambushes be aware though the kPa
you're always watching with the airships
monitoring the red zone 24/7 the red
zone is a spider's we'll have a sniper's
just make sure you get them before they
get you taken back the red zone will
give us the foothold we need to move
into the next song where the KPA are
even stronger this densely populated
area is called the yellow zone and it's
in complete lockdown with the KPA
heavily suppressing people's lives with
people living in complete fear it's up
to us to help show them the way out by
touching their hearts and inspiring
their minds we can show filly that life
doesn't have to be this way blend in
with a crowd and you can sabotage the KP
acecomm channels pack TV radio systems
of broadcast propaganda free prisoners
of the state are suppressed civilians
and destroy or capture their
infrastructure my guys are being held at
the police station and god only knows
what the north's are doing to them we
gotta get them out with you check to the
faience watch the people's attitudes
changed with the resistance and the
uprising becoming more and more
achievement you'll see the city change
around he was a direct consequence of
your actions and believe me we'll need
everyone's help if we're gonna do
the KPA rookie once you've conquered the
red new yellow zones you'll get the
chance to take the fight to the heart of
the KPA in the Green Zone
these are high-value targets where they
exercise total control and they have
these areas armed up to the teeth their
fortresses so you're gonna need every
damn thing you can get if we're gonna
conquer these areas in win this war
make sure you've learned from all your
previous missions rookie otherwise we
haven't got a hope in hell don't let me
down